non-minimalists
are there ways to transform vacant malls
into something valuable for the
community
yes and i think we should yeah so before
i get into my pithy answer here
i want to talk about this because we
have some spaces now
we're seeing this happen now and this is
a better use than just leaving it sit
there
decaying and rotting although i think
sometimes that's beautiful i love
looking at
detroit at its at a sort of bottom
which was somewhere around i don't know
2010 dude like 2009
and the malls the libraries yeah there's
so much schools and libraries beautiful
things
oh my gosh yeah it did there in fact
sean there's a photo essay i don't
remember if it was in slate or new york
times but it was somewhere
the photo essay of new york or of
detroit rather
from about a decade ago and it's
stunning and there's something stunning
about that decay but
we do want to reuse many of these spaces
we can now
a lot of these malls are being bought by
amazon and they're being turned into
distribution centers
now there's a good reason for them to do
it it's actually better for the
environment if they do it
because a few things one is they don't
have to build a whole new space
they get to reuse this space which is
which is better than if they were to
build something right next to it right
right
but also it's right next to the highway
so they don't have to drive 15
20 minutes off of the highway which uses
more fuel
it produces more carbon yeah dioxide et
cetera
and and so it's better for the
environment overall
however i think there are so many other
better uses
that's one use and and if that's going
to work then great i know they're buying
up a lot of
malls and turning them into distribution
centers i would love to see
it's my great hope that we could see a
giant dent get put into the homeless
crisis by
re-appropriating malls it's a great idea
into homeless
centers with services and uh testing and
and medical services and and food and
and
sleeping quarters as a
transitionary space back to
non-homeless life right yeah and because
i
i mean i have so much compassion there's
there's such a problem here especially
in
southern california i think about uh a
fourth
i think it's a fourth of the homeless
population in the countries in
california
yeah in one state it's crazy and and so
there's a large homeless problem here
and
i think that we could address it by
using some of these empty spaces that
are
not ever going to come back right and
that's the thing we have to recognize
this is fluid as i talked about earlier
we built these things to think they
would be permanent
and they could be permanent structures
but the use is not going to be permanent
right
and so i think we can transform them i
also think that we are missing out a
little bit on
community space because these were
the one benefit of the malls you
remember when we were teens we would go
hang out at malls all the time yeah i go
to the middletown mall
me and my brother went there like
several
yeah and so i i spent a lot of time and
now if you look at the middletown wall
you got to see the video i mean it's
terrifying man ryan so ryan managed a
store in in middletown
uh it's in between cincinnati middle
town and and so
you i think you have to you have to look
and say
what is the best use of of these spaces
can they be transformed into
experience spaces i think in some cases
yes can they become more town squares
yes
our friend rob bell who's been on the
podcast a couple times we've been on his
podcast the rob cast
he's written 10 books but before he uh
before
he well before he moved to california he
was a mega church pastor
his church was in a mall an old donated
mall and so it was an abandoned mall
that they donated him and i think 98
maybe
and and so there are a lot of things we
can do with these
spaces that are shockingly more
intentional
than consumerism yeah than the shopping
mall itself
yeah yeah and so here's my pithy answer
for you almost
anything is more valuable than
consumerism
and uh so i i wrote this other thing
down here i don't know if it's a minimal
uh minimal maximum or not abandoned
malls are consumerism
at its terminus an empty carapace
brimming with nostalgia
not meaning and i think there's
something about that
when ryan so in the dayton arcade
yeah so you and i we're finishing up
this new film
with matt diabella called less is now
yeah and
it part of it surrounds i don't know 15
minutes of it now is around this talk
that you and i
went out and gave a bunch of times we
only used a few excerpts from that talk
at this point
but we wanted to give that talk
originally in an abandoned mall
right we just found that it was going to
be really difficult but we finally found
one we found the dayton arcade in
in in downtown dayton
uh proper and and it's this beautiful
abandoned structure it's been abandoned
i think since 89 beautiful decaying mall
yes yeah and there's something just
gorgeous about it in fact we
we had secured it we took two trips out
there we did some filming inside it we
were getting ready to
film the talk and then they found all
this asbestos oh yeah and it was like
oh like we can't have a whole crew of
people here exposed to asbestos for
12 or 14 hours a day yeah that's that
you know 30 years from now they'll have
mesothelioma it would not be a good
thing yeah and so we had to let let that
go even though it was gorgeous
although i think parts of that will
still make make it into the
the film itself there were other malls
that we wanted to use we went actually
toured some other abandoned malls
it just didn't work aesthetically
because they weren't decaying yet so it
just looked weird it looked like
it looked like someone closed them all
for us to film in it and
it didn't work but we ended up finding a
better space anyway so
it worked out really well and i also
wrote about
the dayton arcade in our next book love
people use things and it got cut
somewhere between the third and the
fourth draft
that that section did so i think i'm
going to read it on the maxwell episode
because
there's this whole metaphor about
abandoned malls and how we've abandoned
ourselves
i'm really excited for the uh renovation
of the dayton arcade yes well let's talk
about how they're going to use it
because i think that
that perfectly um that perfectly
addresses onyx or monica's question here
um you've been there yeah so talk about
the space what it look like
it looks post-apocalyptic it's got like
escalators that are
decaying and these high gl uh ceilings
that are glass
with i guess wire or copper like framing
and
um again looks post-apocalyptic uh
you know old stores where you could tell
it was like a sneaker store because you
can just barely see half of a sign that
you can make out the word sneaker
yeah um a lot of old abandoned office
spaces
yeah it's it is uh it's truly beautiful
but
it's weird though because we keep
calling these decaying moths beautiful
it's beautiful for the wrong reasons
though
yeah well i think the thing about the
dayton arcade and we'll go into this
more on the maximal is
it wasn't originally a mall it was a
community space
yeah and it was actually built way
before malls were ever
even invented right it was an indoor and
outdoor
community space there were there was a
market there were offices there there
were apartments
it was the shared living space and
eventually
uh it consumerism took over creed's a
cover
yes and and but now here's the thing it
is being repurposed it's being reclaimed
and because the architecture is some of
the most stunning architecture i've ever
seen
absolutely go ahead and google date and
arcade or we'll put a link to their
website
and in the show notes but they it is
it's amazing what they're doing but
they're turning into a co-working space
there are going to be some shops in
there but it's not going to be retail
centric it's going to be
like a market commission yeah and so
there's a technology lab that's going in
there from the university of dayton
apartments people they're going to use
it as a community space
again and part of that does
involve consuming but it doesn't involve
consumerism
right and i think we need to make that
distinction and so i think the dayton
arcade is actually the best example of
what we can do
when we we take a a structure and we
repurpose it
in a way that is better for the
community and
and doesn't encourage us to over indulge
or to over consume yeah when i read this
question it made me
think about you know reusing things in
general
and i think it's always better to reuse
something if you can
uh or repurpose it yeah so uh my pithy
answer is this
reusing is better than recycling
recycling is
better than refuse refuse is better than
refusing to let go
hmm yeah because sometimes we get caught
up in that well it's going to go in a
landfill
and it's like well you should have
thought about that before you bought it